alexander monroy y es un firmante de paz
el acuerdo de 2016 entre la guerrilla de
las farc y el estado colombiano le dio
la oportunidad de iniciar junto a otros
nueve ex combatientes una marca de
cerveza artesana la trocha lo hicieron
con los cerca de dos mil dólares que les
entregó el estado al desmovilizarse en
la casa de la paz un espacio cultural en
el centro de bogotá tienen una micro
procesadora alexander está clasificando
la cerveza para el fin de semana
vamos a este espacio la casa nosotros
decimos acá cabe todo el mundo sí y es
permitido pensar distinto y no hay
necesidad de matarlos por eso es digamos
como el sueño que nosotros tratamos de
construir aquí
tanto alexander lidera el proyecto doris
suárez que presume de su cerveza la
trocha es muy refrescante muy suave no
se deje engañar porque no es como estas
empresas industriales
cierto que no hemos lancha te puedes
tomar un pentágono borracho estate
antona y muy sabroso
[Música]
librería tienda y exposiciones de
fotografía la casa de la paz es un lugar
de encuentro pese a sentirse abandonados
por el estado más de 280 ex combatientes
han sido asesinados desde la firma dos
meses complicados al compromiso si es
nuestro voto y yo sigo empeñado en la
palabra y comprometido con la fase pero
pues fue un acuerdo de dos partes además
de excombatientes la casa de la paz
alberga otros espacios que es una unión
de costurero que le hicieron una
comisión de la verdad hace muy poco
siento como este para víctimas donde
está virgelina chará que ver con esta
pandemia en su espacio de costura por la
verdad y la memoria entre sus distintos
proyectos destaca este libro sobre la
pandemia
estar aquí es cambiar a estado
imaginario de mucha gente que cree que
porque estamos
víctimas y es combatiente entonces nos
vamos a agarrar a puño puedes decirle a
la gente que hace imaginario está
equivocado un espacio de reconciliación
que parte de la trocha porque como ellos
mismos dicen nada mejor que una cerveza
para poder compartir